EU lawmakers will review for a second  time a blacklist of countries at risk of  facilitating money laundering they say  the list is too short and should include  tax havens like Panama states are  increasingly turning towards private  companies to deal with armed conflict  and security MEP s will look into how to  boost oversight and hold all actors  accountable spearheaded by the  Parliament the world's first  multilingual museum on recent European  history will be opening its doors next  week House and Brussels will look at the  tumultuous 20th century how to encourage  the collaborative economy while also  making sure it follows the rules an  impedes will debate how to regulate  platforms like Airbnb and uber ahead of  a full House vote in mid-may  [Music]